hi there
i'm going to do a short video now
uh touching on a few personal items
and then i'll follow it up with a video
on language learning first of all i had
a
tweet from benny the irish poet
challenging me to
the ice bucket
treatment or whatever ice bucket
challenge
and i didn't really know what it was but
um
i asked my son and apparently within 48
hours i've got to pour a bucket of ice
water on my head
or contribute to a challenge to a
charity
well i have nothing against
cold water i go swimming here in the
ocean when it's 16 70 degrees 17 degrees
centigrade
uh but i'm not interested in pouring ice
water on my head
uh also i uh
i contribute to various causes charity
uh when i feel like it
i
gave five thousand dollars to uh the
serbian flood relief uh that government
website uh some months ago
uh more recently i gave five thousand
dollars to ruslana
the ukrainian singer who is uh doing a
lot of work to help the displaced
internally displaced
persons in ukraine
and i um
wherever i feel that uh i can make a
even a small difference and i think it's
a good thing that people should uh
donate money but i don't like like if
anyone comes to me with a
a chain letter it ends with me so i'm
not i don't feel any great pressure
to respond to that but i at least
recognize the fact that benny is uh
obviously it's a good cause and he's
doing his thing and he shunted it my way
and
i'm not gonna pour
a nice bucket on my head sorry benny but
uh best of luck in in the whole uh
in the whole uh exercise there another
thing is my wife and i are going to be
in montreal on the 16th and 17th of
september
and
if there's any people there who want to
have a meet up it would be great to meet
you all or jose on only whatever it
might be
16th and 17th of september
uh then we're we're gonna be in montreal
uh playing some golf
and from there we're going to europe
and we're going to be in brittany
uh
we're going to be in vann
we're going to be in brest we're going
to be in semalo we're going to be in
love which is in normandy we're going to
be in the champagne area for a couple of
nights before flying back home
this is all sort of between the 22nd
and of september the 5th of october we
have some very good friends in love
a gentleman there is a very good friend
who's gonna who's turned 87 and i
definitely just want to go and see him
so those are some personal uh
housekeeping items if there's any one of
you out there that
would like to meet up in any of those
locations
please let me know and that's all for
those housekeeping